>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> My name is Adam Wittings.
Today we have guest actress,
author, poet, dancer,
and fine artist Miss
Bernadette Stanis,
Thelma Evans of the television
hit series Good Times.
We welcome her today.
[ Applause ]
>> I was born and raised
in Brooklyn, New York.
In the [laugther], in the brown
hood [phonetic] section of Brooklyn
and my mom and dad have five
children at a two bedroom apartment,
you know, a little living
room a little bathroom.
So they raised all seven of
us in that little apartment.
So, I understood when
[laugther] Good Times came around.
I understood it [laugther].
They picked the right girl.
Right? So, born and raised in
Brownville was very challenging.
I'm sure for my parents
to raise two boys
and three girls, but they did well.
I'm being the oldest I had
a lot more responsibility.
My father always told me
-- Bernadette, for one,
if you go wrong, if you go bad,
all of my other children are
going to go bad -- , really?
-- Being the oldest -- , he said, --
you're the leader and they're going
to watch what you do -- .
So, with that in mind, I always
wanted to be the good girl,
you know, to live up to what I
had to do as a responsibility
for my siblings and everything.
I remember my dad, mom, they
being in the projects, you know,
they wanted us to have
a great education.
So, they put us in parochial
school and I remember --
[ Noise ]
They put us in parochial
school, all those popping peas,
I understand that, and [inaudible]
they put us in parochial school
and it was like 10 blocks
away from the projects, okay.
So, every morning we would have
to walk like 10 blocks to school.
And you know how cold the
winters are in New York.
So, we learned character that way,
but we also learned a lot of things
about walking ten blocks
to [inaudible] School --
thank you so much -- .
First of all, we learned about those
junkies, you know, we had junkies
around the corner of the block.
And, as kids, we didn't understand,
you know, the devastation of that.
They were just very
entertaining to us.
So, while we would go to school,
we would always take bets,
[laughter] because, as you know,
when you are on heroin, on heroin --
junkies -- their hands
are very big and --
they nod and they go all
the way down to the floor
but the amazing thing was that
they never hit the ground.
Did you know that?
[Crowd laugther].
And they would stay in a pose for
a very long time, and then they go
down and then they pop right up.
I just thought it was
amazing [laugther] a fine art.
But any way, we learned that,
we learned a lot of things
and my father always
said this to us, "Look,
what's around you does
not have to be in you",
he raised us that way, you know.
So, what you see around you is
what is around you but what is
in you is more important.
And is going to direct
you in certain way.
Now, that was a great lesson for me.
I'm going to just share some
of the lessons that I learned
and that impacted me in my
life time from both my parents.
But this one here is something
that I learned from my mom.
Now, when I was about 10
years old, there was a girl,
there were two girls in my class
called Mary Rose and Caroline --
I'm not going to say the last
names, because they might be
in the audience or
something [crowd laugther].
But any way these two girls were
so beautiful to me and so smart
and they just were everything I
ever wanted to be at 10 years old.
I, on the other hand was not that
smart but I was like okay smart.
I was like a B, C student
but I was hanging in there.
And I remember that they would
always get A's and look great
and all this, so I just wanted to
be in that click, that I want to be,
that was my goal in life
to be a part of them.
And they always absolutely
always rejected me
and it was a hurtful thing
ever since the second grade,
now I'm in the fifth grade
and I'm still trying.
But I figured it out; I figured
it out one day, I said "Duh,
they're A students, I'm not."
So, what does it take
to be an A student?
And I studied and I
studied and I studied.
And I became an A student.
I passed this test with a big
[inaudible] A. I was right there
in their click, in
the elite, you know.
And I remember that day
so happy and I went to --
we had recess and at recess that
we would always play Double Dutch
or a little things like that and so
they were playing Double Dutch --
You all know about
that a Double Dutch?
[Crowd laugther] All right,
you're in my category.
So, I went over to them that day
and I said "Okay, can I play?"
They looked at me the way the always
looked at me and said, "No", I said,
wait a, you know, "Can I play?"
You know, I'm now on
the side of begging.
"Can I please play?"
[Laugther] "No, you can't" And
then they looked at me like,
you got to get out of here.
I was crushed, I was really crushed.
That was a big thing for me.
And so, I went home that evening
and I was crying and, you know,
down and carrying on as I usually
do whenever they do reject me.
And this time it was worse
because I thought I figured it out.
And my mom was there and she
said "What's wrong Bern?"
I said "Caroline, Mary Rose
they still, still don't want me
to be their friends, you
know, I don't understand,
mommy, why is it, why is it?"
And she believed in having answer
for me but she said this to me,
she said "Well, Bern, look at it
like this, you know, some people --
they have talents, you
know, dancing, singing
and that's what you have, you're
talented, and they're very smart.
So, maybe, they don't see, you know,
your value and your things like"--
I didn't want to hear that, that was
like -- that's not going to work-- .
I don't want to be
talented right now.
That was my attitude.
Then I moved around for hours
until my mother finally in the end
of the evening sat down next to me
and she said this, she said "Bern --
one day the whole world is
going to know your name",
but she didn't tell me it
was going to be [inaudible].
[ Crowd laugther ]
So, I listened and I said "Okay,
whatever" But you know what?
I didn't understand what she was
doing and what she was saying
and I realized as an
adult, that, you know,
sometimes a parents are given
certain messages and certain things
to say to their children
in devastating situations,
you know, if they're connected.
I mean to wanting a child
to prosper and she spoke
into my life something,
it taught me to learn --
it taught me to speak
into my children's lives,
what I want for them, you know.
And no matter how bad it may be at
the time, I would say, "You know,
I don't like what you did
but you know you're smart,
you know you're going to be great.
So we can't have those bad things
trimming behind you if you're going
to be a big, great person".
I don't say those things
anyway [laugther].
That was a lesson for me
because when I look back at it,
my mother spoke prophecy
into my life, didn't she?
So that's why, always when I speak
to students at schools and stuff
like that, I always tell them
"You know, listen to your parents,
listen to someone that's older
that's trying to help you".
Because they're nuggets,
they're gone nuggets.
"If you listen you don't have
to go through so much" you know.
And I hope that they hear me,
because it's very important
to listen.
So, that was one of my lessons,
and that's something
I love my mother for.
And then there was this
other one when I wanted to be
in the beauty pageant as a teenager.
And I begged my mother -- Mom,
I want to be in this pageant,
I want to be in this pageant in
this pageant so bad, so bad, so bad,
my mother said -- you sure
want to be in this pageant?
-- I said -- yes -- now
you know this is going
to cost a lot of money, right?
-- You know the gowns, the disk --
the time she got for other kids,
you know, she's got to do this whole
thing every week for the summer.
And I'm like -- I want to do it, I
want to do it, I want to be in it--
So, she finally said -- okay.
So, we got in it.
Now, every Sunday, which [inaudible]
sit down from Brooklyn to Manhattan,
she's got all five of
us, pulling us down to go
to Manhattan to do the rehearsal.
So, this went on for
about seven weeks.
The eighth week was the day
show, the Sunday of the show.
And I got up that morning,
and I looked in the mirror,
and I decided I was not going to go.
I decided that and I meant that.
And my mother said -- okay, it's
time to get ready, you know,
let's go, you know, let's get
it together now -- I'm like --
mom, I'm not going
-- , my mother looked
at me [crowd laugther],
she said -- What?
-- She said -- girl, get
dressed, come on, we've got to go.
She didn't even hear me, I'm like,
"Okay, this is not working" --
I'm really not going -- So, I'm
like, I'm [inaudible] and alone --
, she says-- hurry up, we
have to go -- and I'm like --
okay, all right, [complaining
sounds] -- [laughter].
So, I finally get dressed, we
finally go, we walk into the subway
to go Manhattan, we get on the
train, and I sit far away from her
because you know, I'm
mad [laugther] --
I'm mad, I got the way to
[inaudible] them very mad.
And my mother is paying
me no attention.
She does that sometimes,
pays me no attention.
So, I'm like, "Okay, all right,
she's not even understanding this
at all", so, I sat on that subway,
and I figured, I have an hour.
So I start now.
And I'll start the
mastering up my asthma attack.
Simple, simple.
I would start breathing
deeply [whizzing like asthma].
Now, if anybody has asthma, you
know what I'm talking about,
because if you breathe deeply
enough, you'll catch a whizz.
[Crowd laugther] I got my whizz.
[laugther].
So, I'm whizzing now [whizzing].
We get off the subway and mother
says -- what's wrong with you?
-- I can't do it, mom,
I've got asthma --
[whizzing like with asthma attack].
You know we know our children.
My mother knew me.
She looked at me and she said --
Bernadette, there's a drug store
on the corner, we're
going to go over there
and get a Primatene Mist
[audience and speaker laugther],
you're going to take it, and
you're going to be okay -- .
Uhm, I couldn't get around her.
But you know back you
could get Primatene Mist,
you know, you can't get it now.
But any way, I took the mist,
I sat around for a few
minutes, and I was fine.
And then I had to go on stage.
And I did it.
I wouldn't let her down, you know.
So, now I'm there.
So, I was going to do
what I was there to do.
She said -- you better do what
you've got to do up there [crowd
and speaker laugther] -- .
I knew her better.
So, I did my little thing, you
know, whatever I had to do.
But it really was an amazing thing
because, it was that Sunday that,
there was a manager there
that saw me and told my mom
that they're looking for a teenager
to be in a television series.
And they thought that I might fit.
So, they gave my mother their
card, so that we could go to CBS
and see Norman there,
you know, the next day.
The next day we go off there.
I'm like -- Okay, you know -- I
don't know anything about anything.
It's my first audition and
I don't understand the game.
I don't know what's what.
I'm just walking and following.
So, I get up there with,
at CBS and we open the door
and there were hundreds of girls.
Hundreds. May be not
hundreds [crowd laugther],
may be about 80 or whatever.
But it looked like thousands.
So, I'm sitting there and
I'm like, "Oh my goodness.
Oh, my gosh".
This is weird, okay, well, whatever,
and my mom is looking at me and I'm
like -- I gave us such a hard
time yesterday but I won't,
you know, I won't do it today-- .
But I was thinking about what I did
and how I acted, the day before.
And what came to me, and I'm
going to share this with you,
was actually the reason
why I was acting that way,
was because I was afraid,
I was afraid,
and I was afraid again
in the audition.
But I was really afraid.
And I was afraid that
they wouldn't pick me,
that I wouldn't be good enough,
that I wouldn't be pretty enough,
that I wouldn't make it, that my
talent wouldn't be good enough.
And I just didn't want to hear "no".
I didn't want to hear "no" that day.
So, I figured if I didn't
go, I wouldn't hear "no"
and I would win in my own way.
But what a loser I would have been.
So, the lesson that I
got out of that was this,
don't let fear stop you from
walking into your destiny.
Because, truly, when
something great is
about to happen, fear
does come over us.
You know, we doubt ourselves or
we think "I can't really do this
or what is", and because
of that, all of my life,
whenever that fear came, l
made sure I walked through it.
And I teach my daughters
the same thing --
don't be afraid because when
something is coming for you it seems
like you'll get most afraid -- .
So, that was my lesson there.
Now I'm sitting in this audition.
And I'm like "Okay.
I'm afraid again but I'm
not going to tell mom.
I'm just going to do my thing".
But I kept thinking about
what dad would always say.
And dad would always say
this "What's for you,
no one can take from you".
And I kept thinking
that and thinking that.
And when they called
me for the audition,
I was really weddy
[phonetic], because, you know,
I didn't really know
what it was about.
I just knew that I had to do it.
And I did it, you know, my way.
That's just how I did it.
I would have no fear with that
because it's so big, I mean,
I may go to make it,
I may not, big deal.
So, when I walked in there, it was
Norman Lear sitting behind the desk
with his white hat, you
know, how Norman does.
He's the producer of the show.
And, it was Jimmie
Walker standing there,
with his dumb hat [crowd laugther].
I'm looking at this
guy, I'm like, -- Hewh.
So, any way, they give me a
script, and the script reads
as if someone wrote it
for a girl in the projects
that knew really nothing
about this girl.
So, I'm reading it and it
sounded really not right.
And I'm saying -- excuse
me but mister Lear,
is it okay if I just improvise,
you know, just say what I just,
you know, just improvise --
I knew about improvising,
I knew about that [laughter],
I said -- can I just do that?
Because, see, I have
brothers, I know eheem.
So, he said -- Ohg, Okay, fine,
do it, we've got lots of girls,
do it -- , so, I said -- okay.
So, I got up there and I
said to Jimmie, I said --
Okay, look, you better
clean this house
or least help me clean this
house, you can do the dishes,
you can empty the garbage,
do something,
you're just sitting there
-- so, he said, he said --
I'm not doing dishes, and
the garbage ain't full.
So, I'm not doing anything -- I said
-- , oh, yes, you are going to do --
you know, how you do, and then
he said -- , no, I'm not --
yes, you are -- and I just hit him.
[Crowd laugther].
Because I do that to my brothers.
I just hit him right
on the arm, bang.
And he like -- Huh What?
-- And I'm like -- yeah,
you're going to do it -- .
And he said -- No, I'm not-- .
And we just went back and
forth, then back and forth
and I think Norman was cracking
up, because it was real.
It's just what you do, you know.
So, that was not audition.
[Crowd and speaker laugther] So,
I didn't hear anything
back for about a month.
So, I said, -- hum, I don't
think I did that right --
[inaudible] I should
have read that script.
But it turned out that they did
call me a month and a half later
and they asked for me to go
out to California with my mom.
It was three girls and now
it went down to four of us.
And we had to stay there a week
and we auditioned, we auditioned,
we auditioned and then, I,
about a month after that,
I found out that I got Good Times.
[ Applause ]
Now, I'm now I'm here on Good
Times and I am doing the show
for about six months and I start
realizing that I wanted to do more.
It was like all, I did was come
in and say -- hi mom, hi dad.
Shut up J.J., fight
with him a little bit
and I was back in bathroom.
You all know those sounds.
Okay, so, I mean, I'm
sitting there all day long
in rehearsal, doing
these five lines.
You know, that's a little much.
Everybody else got all these lines.
I'm like -- hugh --
I'm just was bored.
So, Esther and I were like this.
I loved her so much
and she adopted me.
She had to.
She had to take me on
because I wasn't going
to let her not take me on.
I was at her house all the time,
I wasn't bugging her, I loved her.
And so, one day we are at
her house and I said --
Mom, you know, I want
to do more lines,
you know I'm getting
bored -- she says -- What?
-- I said -- I'm getting bored.
She said -- hum -- you know that
-- hum -- [crowd laugther] So,
I'm going -- No, I really am.
I think I can do more, mom, I think
I can do more -- She said -- Really?
-- I said -- Yes -- She said -- Hum.
Okay, okay -- Let me handle it.
-- That was the best -- thank you.
I said -- Okay, thank you.
So, when we did Friday,
we did our rehearsal.
I'm reading out the next script.
Here I am in rehearsal, you
know, we're reading the script.
And of course, I had the same
famous lines, you know, --
Hi mom, hi dad, shut up J.J. and
I'm back in the bathroom -- .
So, at the end of the reading,
Esther said to the producers,
because when we read, we have the
writers, the producers, everybody,
normally everybody is there.
And she said -- I'm going
to ask a question --
she's the star, so they went
-- Oh, yes, Esther, what is it?
-- She said -- I'm going to ask
a question about my daughter.
They got quiet.
And she said -- Are
you ashamed of her?
-- They said -- No, we're
not ashamed of her at all.
She said -- Is she retarded?
[Crowd laugther] -- I'm like
-- you went too far, mom -- .
You know, [laugther] I didn't talk.
I'm like -- please I'm
not, you know, whatever.
So they said -- No,
she's not retarded.
And she said -- Okay,
this is what I want.
My son J.J. has a lot to say, my
son Michael has a lot to say, now,
I want my daughter to have a voice,
and to have something to say -- .
And from that moment
on, I got some lines.
And she looked at me.
She never said another word, she
just looked at me and I said --
Thank you, mom -- , and what I meant
was that I would never let you down.
I will never let you down.
I will get those lines right, I
will be good, I'll do everything.
And I think she's very
proud of me behind that.
She's the one who gave the first
black female teenager her voice,
on television.
I was the first black female
teenager to ever be on television.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
Now while I'm in the thrills
of Good Times I'm like almost
in the fourth season, no,
it was the third season.
And, I'm in the swing of things, a
lot of lines, a lot of everything.
And, I got something called nodules,
because I was taking singing lessons
and I was stringing, you know,
I wasn't doing that right.
But any way, I developed these
nodules on my vocal chords.
So, in the morning,
I would sound normal
but by the time evening
came I sounded like a man.
And they would hurt.
So, I finally had to go to a
specialist and they diagnosed me
and they told me what
they had to do.
And they had to, you know, operate
and that the vocal cords
can go one of two ways.
I mean you can lose
your voice for ever
or you can get very
well and sound normal.
So, they said that the
operation was usually successful.
So, I did the operation.
But before that I mentioned to
my producers, that I'm going
to have this operation,
the doctor said
that I'm not supposed
to speak for six months.
Six months, I'm going
to be off that show.
I thought about it.
And I went to the producers
and I said -- okay, this is it.
I'm not supposed to
speak for a long time.
So, what can you do to
make it work, maybe,
I can speak, you know, a little bit?
-- So they said -- No, you
don't have to speak only
on tape night we'll
allow you to speak --
My doctor said that was fine.
So, therefore, no one really
knew that I had nodules.
I just went right in.
So, I would speak softly, but I
would speak on Thursday nights,
that was the deal, and
I stayed on Good Times.
So, that was wonderful.
In the process, though, of
not speaking, I learned a lot.
You know, we didn't have texts,
we didn't have all that stuff.
So, I had to write out everything.
So, I started writing everything
out and showing people papers
and showing people, -- but then we
didn't have spell check, either.
[laugther] I'm like -- This
isn't going to work out.
They'll think I'm a real dumb.
-- [laugther] so, what I did, so,
what I did was, I prayed a lot
and I asked -- God what is it?
Why? Why did it happen to me?
And stuff like that.
I just prayed a lot, and, you know,
He kind of told me -- just be quiet.
I quieted you down for a
reason -- I'm like -- Really?
And I, you know, I
phoned all the time.
So, I stopped the phone.
I stopped talking so much
and I started writing.
I just started writing people.
They just knew not to speak to me.
It was hard.
It was lonely.
It was weird.
And, what I started to do was write.
I started by poetry.
And the most amazing poetry
came to me, because I was quiet.
And I listened.
And, before that I didn't
have time to write no poetry.
I was so busy talking.
So, sometimes when God
does something in our lives
that may be devastating to us,
but if we ask him why this is?
He'll give you the answer
to why He's done it.
And if you listen,
that's your benefit.
So, what I did is this
wonderful poetry
and I started my writing career.
I started writing all
the time, ideas will come
to me, just beautiful things.
And I just thank God for that
because although I lost my voice,
He gave me a voice on paper.
So, something sometimes
we have to just understand
that why did it happen to you?
Why not? Happened for a reason.
And what I did was gave
birth to my career now.
I didn't know that I would be a
writer but I knew I loved writing
and writing was in me
and I was a good writer.
And so, it gave birth to, later on,
I wrote a book called Situations
101 Relationships The Good the Bad
and the Ugly.
Most of you probably do have
that book because I was here
with that book, first time.
And that book came about
because, as life went on,
and I'm a mature lady now, I
learned a lot about relationships.
And my mom was very instrumental
in that also because being back
in those days, those ladies got
married, you know, she dated my dad
when she was 16, they got married
when she was 20 and that was it.
No other man, no other
body would do daddy.
So, I would say -- Mom,
you know, I'm out here --
You know, I'm Thelma -- I'm out
here and what is it, you know,
how do you get this guy, I mean, the
relationship stuff is not working,
like I thought it should
work -- She says --
Bern, I can't help you
-- Ma, you can't help me?
You got to help me -- She said --
I can't help you, I don't know the
world, I don't know what's out,
I don't know how it works -- .
She said -- but I'm
going to tell you this,
I want you to read
everything you could read,
I want you to ask questions
and study.
Study all you want to study
about relationships --
Because she felt bad
she couldn't help me.
So, she gave me permission to go
into relationships, study them,
learn things, you know,
and I did that.
So, I was pretty equipped on,
you know, helping some people,
not all people, but some
people about relationships.
I became the girlfriend that
every would call and talk
about their stuff, you know what I
mean, and because I was out there
with them, you know, they
were just my friends.
I didn't know all their friends.
So, I would give them good
advice and they felt safe
because I couldn't go and tell
their friends what they said,
you know, I was like that.
So, I would give them great advice
and they would keep coming back.
So, everything that's in the book is
advice that I have given to someone.
So, I did 101 different situations
but there are so many more.
But this one girl, the reason
why the book came about,
was this one girl kept
asking me about this one guy.
So, it was 3 o'clock in the morning
and she was calling me nonstop.
And I said to her --
Wait a minute --
I picked up the phone and
I said -- What's wrong?
-- She said -- I can't reach him,
I can't, I can't -- I'm like --
, you can't reach him, it's
3 o'clock in the morning.
Could he be sleeping?
-- [Crowd laugther] -- No, I
don't think it's like that,
I don't think it's like that.
I left him a lot of messages
and you know-- , I said --
well-- I called a few times-- .
And I go -- okay, how
many times you called?
-- Well, you know, like 15
-- [crowd laugther] I say --
Wait, wait, wait, hold on there.
This is obsession -- .
I said -- did you leave
a message each time?
-- Yes, I did.
-- I said -- , he might
not ever call you back.
But anyway, I didn't say
that really, I thought that.
So, I said to her --
Look, I'll tell you what,
I'm going to write some things out
for you that you can look at look,
you know, you can put
on your refrigerator.
So, in the middle of the
night, you know, you don't have
to call your friends
up, wake them up,
and tell them you called
somebody by the 15 time.
And get through it through the
night and then call in the morning,
you know, we can talk
in the morning -- .
So, she said -- All right -- So,
I started writing these things.
I said -- I want you to put them
on your refrigerator and, you know,
in the middle of the night,
you get up, you walk around,
you read it, it's right there.
She said -- Okay -- .
And I said -- well, if that
doesn't work for you do like I do,
open the refrigerator and eat
something -- [crowd laugther].
So we do. So, anyway, she would have
laughed with that but, you know,
I started writing and writing and
that's how the book developed.
I felt I was writing
so much, I kept writing
and writing and the book came.
So, there are always
all little gifts
and things like that along the way.
And then there was this,
I thought I was touring
with the book Situations
Relationships,
I realized that people are breaking
up mostly because of finances.
So, it came on me to write the book
on simple financing and how you feel
with your money, relationship with
your own money and how you feel
with sharing your money
with other people.
And people don't address that, they
just go into a relationship and --
we're not going to talk about money,
we're not going to talk about money.
-- Six months into
the relationship --
we're not going to
talk about money -- .
Come on. And then when
you say something --
I want to buy something -- why are
you spending your money on that?
-- You know, you have to
know where your money mind is
when you're dealing
with people, you know.
First of all, you have to ask
them -- do you have good credit?
-- A lot of times they're
hope you have good credit.
So, and vice-versa don't
just go one way [laughter].
That credit is a big deal,
baby, in relationships.
So, I start writing about
that and talking about that.
Then, after that, that was the book
mommy and I were touring together
and that's when I said to her --
Mommy it would be nice if you
had a book too and you could sit
with me and things like that.
And, you know, that's
when, you know,
we realized that that
would never happen.
But I got my mom in 2006 and I
want to share something with you.
While doing all that book signing,
I had an 8-year old daughter
and an 18-year old daughter.
Those are delicate ages, and
I had mommy, and of course,
I had my husband which
was helping me.
But you're dealing with a
mother, and daughters and mommy
and the dynamics of that, and my
heart being in different places,
and I realized that my little
daughter who was 8 years old,
was very jealous of my
mother, when she came,
because I gave my mother all the
attention because my mom was sick.
And I'm, oh my God, you know,
and my baby's getting --
Why you have to treat her like that?
-- Because she was getting,
you know, she was a baby.
And so, one day my mom said to me --
I don't know why Britney is jealous
of me, who wants to be like this?
-- I said -- Mom, she's going to
get it together, because, you know,
you're not going to
be like this always.
You know, we're going to solve
this -- My older daughter,
she was watching from the distance
because she was ashamed,
which is okay.
You know, she didn't want
her friends to see her,
you know the kind of thing.
I understood that.
In the meantime, I'm realizing
that my mom has this Alzheimer's
and when I first -- when she
was first diagnosed with it,
I looked at the doctor and I said --
Okay, well, what is
it, minerals, vitamins?
You know, what do we
have to do here?
-- I said -- Because
we're going to solve this.
-- So, the doctor looked
at me and went.
And he didn't say anything.
And I thought that was very rude.
I'm like -- That's ugly.
We're going to find another doctor.
This doctor is not right.
-- And another doctor.
The doctor gave me
the same kind of look.
But what they were saying to me is
that -- this chick is in denial.
She's ignorant.
She does not know what
this thing is.
Alzheimer is a death sentence.
-- I didn't understand that.
I fought like you would never
believe, on the internet,
finding ways, crying,
praying, going to everybody.
There's got to be an
answer to this thing.
It was driving me crazy.
It did that for about
three, four years.
In the meantime, as a care
giver, you have got to be careful
because you could lose yourself,
my pressure went up, my weight went
out of control, you
know what I mean?
And I'm like -- I can't
be gaining weight,
I'm an actress, what is this?
I'm getting weight, oh my God --
You know, I'm going through that
because my mom would
eat, forgets she ate
and would want me to
eat with her again.
And I loved her so much
I ate with her again.
I mean, I was going through
it, you know when I realized
that I was really, really heavy?
Was when I went, I was
buying some clothes,
because for some reason my clothes
were getting tight, you know,
and so I had to get
some new clothes.
So, I went to Galls and Clothes
and I saw the size of the clothes
and I said -- Oh my God, this
doesn't even fit, you know what?
They got European clothes
in here [laughter] I was
in such a denial of everything.
You know, but I realized
it wasn't the clothes,
so the doctor told
me I had to calm it
down because the pressure
was high, it was the weight,
it was whole life thing so
I started looking like that.
But still, my attention wasn't
quite on me, it was still on my mom.
But what you do in a situation
like that, you start mourning,
you don't really you
are realize mourning.
I'm mourning the loss of my mother.
I'm mourning the fact that
she was, she was a bookkeeper,
and she started to give her
money away to everybody.
She would hide her money, I
would see in drawers 200 dollars,
150 dollars -- I went --
Mom, what are you doing?
Then I realized that's what they do.
So, what came to me one day,
and this is very major to me,
what came to me one day was the fact
that -- I'm going to go to the store
and get it play money I'm going take
this chance, I went and I got a pack
of play money, I took her
money out of the purse
and I put the play money in it;
and she opened up her purse,
and she said -- Oh, I got
my money, got my money.
And I said -- Okay -- she took
the money out and was counting it.
She saw the tens, the fives,
the 20s, and count the money.
She said -- okay.
-- She put it back in, she was fine.
I went in that bathroom
and I cried like a baby
that my mother no longer knew
the difference between real money
and play money, you know,
that's very devastating.
These are the things
that I had to deal with.
As a caregiver for a
person that has Alzheimer's.
But I'm going to get to the
end of this now and I'm going
to let you know that the
disease is very devastating,
and it's very devastating
on the caregiver.
And you have to come
to grips with the fact
that Alzheimer's is now
still a death sentence.
There is no cure, they
can't fight for this.
I'm here to fight because
they can't, they can't.
And so, it went on where, you know,
at the end of the road she went
through all the stages and
at the end mommy was, mommy,
she got shingles because
she had the shingles,
you know, whatever that was.
So, I gave her the feeding tube,
I let her have the feeding
tube, put the feeding tube in.
And my mother was always at
home with me, and they asked me
to put her in a facility because
she wasn't sick enough to be
in the hospital and she wasn't
well enough to really come home
because I didn't know how
to handle feeding tubes.
For two weeks, I put
her in this facility.
I looked, and looked, and looked
and I found a very nice
facility, I thought.
And I put her in it.
And so, the second week I said --
Okay, well I'm here too, you know,
get all arranged so mom can come
back home and then looked at me
and they said -- Your
mom can't come back home
because she caught the C. difficile
disease, that's the staff disease
that goes around in a nasty
facility because, I found out,
that it happens because the maids
of the aids that are taking care
of these people, want
to do it quick.
And nobody can tell, the
person can't tell on them.
So, what they do is they
get a little basin of water,
they get a little towel and they you
go to each person bring that towel
over them, and then
they'll wipe them.
That's done but the paper
on them, let them go,
next one, next one, next one.
They don't use soap.
All it took was some soap, and the
staff disease would not have spread.
That was very devastating to me.
So, my mother was stuck
in there for a minute,
I was trying to get her out.
I got her into another facility.
And, eventually, she
caught pneumonia, you know.
And they had to take
her to the hospital.
But I wanted to tell you
about the last night.
The day before the last night,
I was literally losing my mind.
She's in the hospital, she
has tube down her throat,
things like that, she can't speak.
And so, I'm realizing this
is not good, you know,
I noticed that her food fell,
I noticed certain things
but she was calm, she was there,
she was there, she's aware.
And she would go in and out so, it
wasn't at the end of Alzheimer's.
So, she could still
communicate with me,
before Alzheimer's she
communicated with me.
So, the day before they put the
tube down, she was in hospital,
the day before they
put the tube down.
She said to me, when I went
to the hospital, and I said --
Oh, mommy, how are you doing, mom?
Everything is going to be okay.
-- And she looked at me and she
said, just before I had to leave,
she said -- I want you to take care
of yourself because we all have
to take care of ourselves now -- .
I'm like -- why are you saying that?
-- But I knew why she
was saying that.
So, the next day she had this
thing in her throat and everything.
It lasted for about a month.
Then the day before the last
night, I was going nuts.
I was calling the doctors,
I was accusing them --
look, you're not do, give her some
yogurt, give her some antibiotics,
give her something,
give her probiotics,
that's what you ought
to do, you ought to do.
-- I called those people every day,
every hour on hour and they said --
Look, your mom is very,
very ill -- I'm like, --
that's why she's there you know,
fix her, get her right -- .
So, that night, I went to see her
and I told her the next morning
that I had to do a speech for
the Alzheimer's Association
and I was going to speak about her.
It was about 11 o'clock,
and I said --
Okay mommy right after that
I'm going to come back here,
it would be about 10 o'clock,
I'll be back here, okay?
-- And she said -- Okay -- .
I kissed her and that was it.
You know, I went home,
and that night,
about 2.30, my cell phone rang.
Now, I had my daughter,
she's like 16 now,
and me and my other
daughter was at her apartment
and my husband was in New York.
So, it was just she and I.
I didn't go to bed,
we laid on the couch.
She laid on one couch
so I laid on the couch.
The phone rang and she looked at it.
Because I wasn't looking at it.
She looked at it and she said --
Mommy, that's the hospital
-- , you know.
I said -- Yeah, yeah?
-- And I let it go to voice
mail I wouldn't pick it up.
She said -- Mommy, you
got to call them back.
You got to call them back.
-- I said -- okay.
So, I called back, and they said --
your mother's vitals are
failing, please, come in now.
-- And I'm like, that moment,
everything changed,
everything changed.
It was like, you don't
know at the moment
of "this is it moment",
what you're going to do.
I froze. I wouldn't
move, I couldn't move.
I was like [breathing hard].
And my little daughter said to me --
Mommy, come on, they must waiting,
you have to come, we have to come.
Come on, mom.
-- She said, -- come on
now, here's your blouse.
-- I put my blouse on.
She said, -- here are your pants.
-- I put the pants on.
She said, -- here's your hair.
[ Laughter ]
What the hell.
I'm glad she said that [laughter].
The hour we woke up, I
wouldn't have the hair.
So, I put my shoes on, she gave
me my purse, she gave me my keys
and I'm still looking at them like.
And I got Alice say -- Mommy,
put it together because you have
to drive, I can't drive, ma.
-- So, I said, -- Okay,
call your sister.
-- So, she called.
The hour, we all met
at the hospital.
I made it to the hospital.
When I got upstairs in the
room I'm like -- Oh, my God.
What is this going to be like?
What am I going to do,
what am I going to say --
And at that moment
God gave me grace.
He gave me grace.
He said to me, it was like He
just dropped something on my brain
and it went like this, He said
-- This is going to happen.
It's not about you.
So, make it good for her.
-- I know exactly what that was.
So, when I walked in
there, mommy was at peace.
It felt like the Holy Spirit
was, like, in the room.
It felt so peaceful.
And I walked in and I was okay.
I said -- Okay, ma.
-- I said, -- Okay, mommy.
I'm here. I said, -- me
and the girls are here.
We're going to be with you.
-- I said, -- Mommy,
I'm going to lay
down with you until
this happens -- .
I said -- I don't care
if takes a day, a week,
a month -- , and I meant that.
And I told them to move her
over so I could lay down.
They looked at me like -- What?
She got tubes, you can't move her.
-- I said -- Either you move
her or I'm going to move her.
Because I'm laying down
with my mother -- .
So, they moved her over, they
gave me a little blanket,
they gave me a little
pillow, because ah --
they knew they couldn't
mess with me that night.
So, they gave me a little
blanket, a little pillow and I laid
down with mommy, and I
put my foot over mommy
and I said -- Mommy, I'm here -- .
And I touched her hand, rubbed
her hand and everything.
And I wanted to put my hand on her
chest but she had the respirator,
I couldn't do that, you know,
thoughts, things like that.
So I go I can't, can't do that.
But I'm here, mommy.
And it was so peaceful.
My two daughters went into the
waiting room and went to sleep.
And I lay there, and the clock is
right there, and I'm laying there,
you know, peaceful,
and I went to sleep.
I went to sleep for two hours.
And I couldn't believe I did that.
And when I woke up, it was like
two hours later, and I was like.
And I'm looking at my mom.
Oh, God. And mommy
was still breathing.
And she was still looking around.
And I said, -- Oh God,
thank you -- .
And then the priest came in --
no, the pastor came
in to give her rights
and he said it was very peaceful
in here and that I was brave
and different things like that.
And then, my daughters came
in, I had them come in.
And my older daughter was looking
at my mother, she came around,
she was looking at her, and talking
to her, and touching her face
and she said -- Mommy -- ,
she said -- Mama's eyes --
they call her mama -- Mama's
eyes don't look right.
-- I said -- What do you mean?
What do you mean?
-- Don't look right, it's just
like she's looking through,
she's looking through, ma -- .
And I'm like, okay, we'll give
her, show her the picture of Jesus.
So, she showed her
the picture of Jesus.
She said, -- she's not, she's
not focused -- So, I said --
Well, show her a picture of Mary --
, so she showed her a picture
of Mary because she loved Mary.
And she still was like, she said --
Mommy, she's looking like she's
looking right through these papers.
-- So I said -- Okay,
I knew it was time.
I went around and I looked at her.
And I looked in her eyes.
And I realize my God, you know,
I'm looking in the eyes of death.
Her eyes were yellow
and little tinny,
little red blood shots were coming.
And I'm like, oh, God.
I said -- This is it.
I got to, I got to start talking
to her, I got to tell her now.
-- So I said -- Mommy, I want
you to know that we had fun.
We had a good time, mommy, -- I
said -- I love you, I love you,
I love you, I love you --
I said it so many times.
And I realize she can't
say I love you back.
So, I said -- I know
you love me, mommy.
I know you love me.
-- I said, -- But we had
fun, we had a good time
but it's not over yet -- .
I don't know why I said that.
And she left.
She left. I wouldn't say she died.
I would say she left
because it's a transition.
And if you know, if you know the
Spirit of God, let me tell you,
the body was no longer
any good to her.
But that woman still lives.
It's not over.
And that's what I meant.
And then, of course, they took
me out, brought me in, you know,
they took me out, you know,
code blue, the whole thing,
asked me what I, do I
want them bring her back?
You know, like they ask you.
And I said -- Yes,
bring my mother back.
-- They brought her back
one time, she went again.
They said, -- If she
comes, she leaves again,
do you want to bring her back?
-- , -- Yes, bring her back -- .
By this time, my kids had called
my brother who was a pastor.
And he's listening to me
demanding that she comes back.
And he says -- Bernadette, stop it.
Let her go.
Let her go -- .
So, I let her go.
That was it.
And after that I realized that I had
to write a book, I had to write it
because I wanted the
world to know who she was,
as a special person, who my dad was.
Everybody's parents are special.
But they are my only two parents.
So, I had to write it.
And I shared a lot of
things in that book.
It took me five years to
write it, because I would get
to certain points and I had to
let go, I couldn't go any further.
But I knew I had to write this
book because there's so many people
that are not talking about
Alzheimer's, they're not talking
about care giving, they're
suffering in silence, like I was.
I was suffering.
And I wouldn't share a lot,
you know, because, you know,
you think people want
to know, you know.
And I feel like there are a lot
of people out there that are going
through and will go
through what I went through.
And I only wished that I had that
book when I was going through it
because I wrote it like a
companion book, like a friend.
Because I could read about
the steps of Alzheimer's,
I could read about this and read
about that but nobody would talk
about the pain or the
compassion or the fact
that you're mourning your loved
one, as you're taking care of them.
And you could be losing yourself.
A lot of care givers die before
the person they're caring for.
You know, I was on my way because
I was, I had forgotten about me.
So, I'm just sharing these things
with you because it's very real
and one day, we all may be there.
So, that's why I wrote The Last
Night because it was the last night
that showed me the power of
God and how He can heal us,
and He can make it okay, He can
make you understand, you know,
when you have to understand.
So, I thank you for listening to me.
>> Any questions?
>> Yeah. I have comments and
a testimony [inaudible] So,
I [inaudible] what you said
about understanding your
relation with elders.
My grandmother used to [inaudible].
Walk by the town and
you'll get, you know, free.
Lie down and [inaudible]
wake up with flees.
When many times [inaudible]
flies out the window [inaudible].
Hi, grandma, just, just shut
it, you know, and then I got 15
when my [inaudible]
wouldn't get through.
>> But you were listening,
see, was in your head.
>> You know, my grandma was
so wise and then suddenly,
what I want to say is I went through
a similar experience with my aunt
because she was my
aunt, not my mother.
>> Right.
>> So, she would slide
into dementia, and I,
at first I was embarrassed, because
I was like, why is she acting
like that and then I realized,
oh, oh, this is serious.
My aunt got on a plane by
herself to Paris where I was
and called the hotel phone office
and you have to take this lady
out of here, she's, you know,
incontinent all over the place,
and you know, I'm still trying
to get my aunt dignity but I end
up spending the rest of my
trip to Paris babysitting.
And I was very resentful, why do
I have to take care of this woman?
You know, my parent,
my father's sibling,
why do I have to take
care of my aunt.
>> Yeah.
>> And being the only person who
lived and watched this situation
with her, just like she kept all
day long, and people call me up,
your aunt's wandering
on the street, you know,
she's like her credit cards are
falling out of her purse and stuff.
And it was just the
worst thing ever.
And, I went to go see Dream
Girls of these images theater
and I got a call before I
went in, it was somebody
with my aunt's cell phone,
of course, found it there.
I had my dad to find her.
And it stayed with me years
to come to terms with my aunt.
But she was nice, she was nice
till the end [inaudible] fell.
But I had a responsibility
toward her, and I just got
out a horrible thing where
some people were trying to,
they try to take advantage of
her for her money for years.
And, we had some crooks
doing, infiltrating themselves
into her will etcetera, and I would
say it passed years of they going
to court, you know, fighting for
my aunt, she lost her sister,
her older sisters for money.
Her older sister died
April 29 [inaudible].
>> That's so sad.
>> Over $700,000 [inaudible].
>> It was, but you
know, I feel like now
that my aunt's spirit is at rest.
My [inaudible] wasn't
because she was so attached
to her things, and her money.
And, now, he finally got
some kind of resolution
but still very hard to,
first of all, [inaudible].
It took everything out of
me, taking care of my aunt,
getting calls at work, your
aunt is, you know what --
>> But you did it.
>> Caring.
>> But you I did it.
>> I did.
>> I know, I know it's
hard but sometimes we are,
I'd say blessed with
the responsibility.
And we learn a lot in the process.
And you never know why we
need to know that knowledge,
and it's okay to be resentful,
it's okay to feel bad,
it's okay to say, "Why me?"
Because those are the
things we felt through.
It happens.
Why? You know, I still question
why in certain ways, but, you know,
if you have faith and you
believe that everything happens
for a reason, you will get over that
in time and you will not feel guilty
or bad or anything,
because it's human.
It's very human.
I went through the
same thing at first.
I would say -- God,
come on, why my mom?
-- You know, -- why?
-- You know.
>> [Inaudible] says that when she
was the first [inaudible] and chief
of the nurses and staff of NIH
of veterans administration.
>> Wow.
>> I saw her reduced to
>> That's right.
That's right.
And that's a very horrible place
but that's what this disease does.
And we need to know why it happens,
and what we can do to prevent it
from happening to us,
especially to me
as they say that it's in the family.
You know, I feel it's
not in the family,
it's in the habits,
it's in the habits.
The things that we do that our
parent did, my mother was a warrior,
she worried about everybody and
so, you know, maybe the stress
of it all did too, my father
was murdered when she was 59.
And I think that it
threw her into it.
She went straight into
Parkinson's in that ten year span.
By the time she was 72
she was into Alzheimer's.
So, yeah, yeah, it's
rough, it's rough.
>> Do you have a question?
>> I don't have a question but I
want to see if the last ten years
into [inaudible] she can walk with
some restrain, maybe, you know,
[inaudible] this is the whole.
>> The whole mess.
>> But the road is so
painful [inaudible].
>> Yes, yes.
And the questions that we may
have, you ask the Lord to show you,
reveal it, reveal why this is
happening, reveal why it happens
to me, why I got it, you know,
I mean, we have siblings,
that they say, you
got her [laughter].
I got my mama.
You know, and sometimes they
say, I would [inaudible] say --
Well, you know, why don't you just
call, you know, a lot, you know,
send a little card, you know -- .
But she can't remember anyway.
That's not the point, the
point is -- you are the child,
you are the grandchild, you
remember her though -- .
Yes.
>> I think it's another thing
with your parents [inaudible].
He said, [inaudible]
and I couldn't figure
out [inaudible] times why she
was a changed person because,
and I kept [inaudible] to my arms.
Why it happened, why
[inaudible] this and that.
And [inaudible] you
just have to learn.
>> Well.
>> This is your [inaudible] and
certain things you don't know
about just as you [inaudible].
>> Yes.
>> But it happen [inaudible]
into her mother
>> So, it's just, but
you see you have
to understand what
the disease does, see.
When, first of all,
they have no filter.
They lose the filter,
they lose the filter
and they say horrible
things sometimes.
They say embarrassing things to
you sometimes, but you have to look
at it and say -- Hum
maybe I am a little fat,
maybe I will to lose a little weight
-- [laughter] You know, but, yeah,
may not like that but it's
a little true, you know.
There is no filter but then you say
this, you say -- It's not my mama.
My mama would never say that to me
-- , you know, -- Mama wouldn't -- .
She would just say -- Bern, you
know there's a little weight
over there -- Nice.
But my mother said
it and I'm like, uhm,
but it's the disease that's
saying it, not your mommy.
Not your mother.
And there are different
ways they act.
Like, if they get the disease that's
affecting the back of the brain,
it goes to different places.
And in the back of the brain,
they're usually peaceful;
my mother was very peaceful
anyway, so it was very peaceful,
she was very peaceful, very
agreeable, listen, wonderful.
Then, you can get it
in the frontal lobe
which makes you very aggressive,
very mean, and very nasty.
But it's not them, it's the part
of the brain that's, you know,
and they get very aggressive.
So, understand what
you're dealing with.
It's not -- Oh, she's
nasty, she's mean -- .
You know, you might be
a little nasty and mean
but you know, it gets worse.
But understand what that is.
It's a lot of understanding
in this thing.
>> Next question.
>> [Inaudible].
It certainly was my uncle,
[inaudible] through the years,
[inaudible] following years.
He was a very peaceful,
[inaudible] friend.
[Inaudible] And later on, he started
to [inaudible] and [inaudible].
But he would tell us it must have
happened that he was younger.
>> Yeah, they do, they go back
to young, their young life.
My mother stopped at 14.
And that was her best time, and
there was a buddy Willis [phonetic],
buddy Willis, she was like
buddy Willis, in high school.
So, every time I wanted to make
her smile and make her happy,
I would say -- Mommy, come on,
let's talk about buddy Willies -- .
And she just smiled, and she
talked about high school and talk
about her friends then, it was then.
So, you know, she knew I was her
daughter, she knew I was close
because she loved me, she knew the
connection but I became her mom.
She called me mom.
Yeah, I became her mom, and
she was my baby some days.
And she mentioned to
my husband one time --
No, you know I have a husband -- .
[Laughter].
She says I know mom, I know you got
a husband, where's your husband.
But you see, I don't think she
remembered he died, you know
but she knows, she had a husband.
So, it's funny, you know,
they go through stuff.
And you just have to
love them through it.
And agree, agree, agree.
I mean, sometimes, it's like,
she would go, the babies are big
in their life, you know,
they hallucinate a
little bit and see babies.
My mother saw babies and she
would say -- Okay, now, you know,
watch the baby over there, watch the
baby over there, and I'm like, --
Mommy -- at first I went like Mom
-- there's no babies over there.
And then I realized it
-- Okay, we'll watch it.
Okay, so tell me exactly where that
baby is so I won't step on one --
she said -- okay, it's
right there -- .
Now, I'd walk around
the imaginary baby.
>> [Inaudible] can
hear them [inaudible].
>> He did.
>> Towards the end.
>> Toward the end.
>> Spoke very, very nasty
things, you know, it was
>> Hurtful.
>> It was really hurtful but
[inaudible] unless he was like that,
he would [inaudible] to us.
>> Well, it's not that
they're like that before.
It's like they know
something is wrong with them
and they can't get it out.
They know something it's not right,
they don't have the
language anymore, you know.
Some people treat them differently.
It becomes like, you know,
a baby senses things.
So, they can be around a
person and get very violent,
and very nasty and very stubborn.
But the person, you got to know
what that person is saying to them.
Or how that person is treating them.
You see, but if it's a loving,
loving, loving relationship,
a lot of times they
don't do that like that.
Because people think -- Well,
they're not going to remember
that I disgusted out,
or I kicked them,
or I pushed them to
the side -- Serious.
And they know -- you
just kicked me --
, but I think they can't
say it, so they get violent.
Right
>> You have to really
[inaudible] careful.
>> You do.
>> And, you know, not do the
triggers that make them angry.
>> Right.
>> Because my aunt, would be like,
if you told my aunt, you know,
she had a [inaudible] or a cocktail
and so you say [inaudible]
you need that cocktail.
-- What are you telling -- ?
>> That right, I'm wrong.
[Inaudible] telling me I can't have
my cocktail [laughter] and see,
what she, she meant that.
A cocktail.
But she's a grown woman
and she wants her cocktail.
>> I knew it myself she requested
that she may [inaudible].
>> That's right.
Did you give her the cocktail?
>> Well, what would I do
if she [inaudible] then she
walked away, and I drank it.
>> And she didn't know
she didn't drink it?
>> Maybe she did.
>> Okay. So, that's how
you have to do, you know.
>> [Laughter] well,
it didn't go to waste.
All right.
>> Miss Bernadette.
>> Yes.
>> I wanted to make sure
I see you and let you know
that God makes no mistakes
and you being here
with us today is blessing
each and every one
of us who were able to come.
I appreciate this intimate talk.
And also, I appreciate your talent
and gift as an actress and a writer
because growing up with
the show Good Times,
that was our leave it or be.
[Laughter].
>> And the content of that
show touched many hearts
with the reality, the
harsh realities of life.
>> Yeah.
>> But the one thing I
can say is to memories,
you can always remember
the Good Times.
>> That's right.
Thank you so much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.